ma bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj esatto era
esattamente quello che volevo siamo
tornati sugli under simulator ragazzi
perché stamattina è uscita la versione
nuova io mi sono infilato come un
opossum apprende io posso non si
infilano non lo so io di certo se non ha
scoperto l'ultima volta la mission mode
che è veramente una figata pazzesca che
è sta roba dove lui ti da un obiettivo e
tu devi farlo fuori c'è lei ti da un
obiettivo ciao ziata posto l'altro pure
una rossa sapete come si dice no rossa
di capelli dalmazzo coi coltelli andiamo
avanti su random mission mina rai deve
uccidere una che si chiama mina rai
va bene a mina rai sicuramente non piace
mediaset che battuta di merda ragazze e
ragazzi non è che non è possibile che vi
state tutti accalcati ma fate un po per
volta santo iddio la divisa nera per
tutti quindi deve averla divisa nera e
la fascia e amica come faccio a
riconoscerla eccole questa sei tu mina
rai rai mina si situa quanto vedo ciao
zia posso parlarti ma che bella ragazza
che sei se veramente una figata [__]
ucciderti in realtà ragazzi quando le
ragazze si fanno i complimenti a vicenda
in realtà pensano questo l'uno
dell'altra voi non lo sapete io sia
facendo stando vicino alle tipe imparo
le cose fantastico i gossip ma faccio lo
gas
ecco lei non lo ammazzano mai comunque è
domandata perché io perdo la gente non
sono capace neanche a giocare un gioco
così eccola devo ammazzare la zia allora
signore e signori non so come fare
questa cosa a parte il coltello il
coltello ragazzi e un coltello che ho
trovato qua dentro ce l'avevate voi
quindi inutile che fate gli
scandalizzati subito subito metering
natale ammazzavo sempre sempre sempre
dopo le dopo la lezione sempre e invece
stavolta non so per quale motivo sono
riuscito ad ammazzare la prima
incredibile allora sono tra sporca di
sangue però usciamo usciamo
no non mi serve niente grazie dire
perché potrò farmi le cose potrò farmi
delle cuffie una pozione letale un
pacchetto di sigarette e uniforme pulita
benissimo non ho capito con quale
criterio ma non si possono fare queste
cose siamo studio tintoria ragazzi vi
dico nell'ultimo episodio per fare
questa cosa ci avevo messo 12 anni
perché non riusciva mai ad ammazzarla
non riusciva mai a trovarla riuscivo a
fare un cazzo nell'ultimo episodio è
solo ammazzata subito in dieci
prodotto figlio di [__] cosa ci fai
alle 7 del mattino combaciato vicino i
rifiuti spiega ma anche l'ultima volta
era morto così ma non capisco perchè c'è
gente li dà a volte c'è a volte non c'è
non capisco sapete ragazzi cosa vi dico
per farla molto più semplice per non
farla così guarda non so se riusciamo ma
proviamoci
siccome ogni volta che provo ad
ammazzare la tipa ovviamente mi sporco
tutto di sangue perché non lo ammazzo da
nuda così almeno non mi si possono
sporcare i vestiti è [__] genio ab e
volendo posso anche andare in giro così
nude nude nude perfetto nuda e sporca di
sangue ragazzi feticismo qua prego iddio
che faccia la stessa strada di prima se
magari riesco a beccarla sempre nello
stesso corridoio associata dove passa
dove la tipa l'ho persa dove la tipa
evidentemente non usano le stesse strade
ogni volta porca vacca laida peccato
sono tutti in classe ma sono le sette e
un quarto cosa fatta in classe arti
marziali
ecco la trovata devo non vi
scandalizzate che sono nuda sì un po si
scandalizzano quindi start waiting light
quindi questo è il prescuola fantastico
bello quell'esercizio che stai facendo
molto utile
allora facciamo passare il tempo finché
la zia non esce allora quello è uscito
devo solo capire dove esce lei sono a
nudo zione antistante lo so che vi sto
già tua madre una volta nudo non ti
scandalizzata però mi che è pieno di
gente che palle o ma libera.tv di
persone sta andando in classe sta
andando li mortacci sua quindi mi tocca
aspettare porca eva non devo fare
neanche taglia dove la mia lezione cava
dove la sua stessa classe veramente che
culo non fa niente se mi presento nuda
in clan
ma chi se ne frega language vediamo no
nessuno se ne è accorto che sono nuda va
bene cioè si scandalizzano se giro con
una mazza da baseball al ma se giro nuda
nozio per caso la intrattenesse ferma
fermati fermati parla con mè dini
qualcosa delle quali non me ne frega un
cazzo gossip sempre ti piace sempre a
mio dio sembra così schifoso schifoso
sempre vissuto ha insultato sempre
tono di guarda come ti permetti di
nessuno ha visto niente nessuno ha visto
niente nessuno ha visto niente niente
ono state vedendo sono nuda polizia mi
molestano non vale però ero nuda non
puoi toccarmi ragazzi cambiamo bersaglio
che mi sa che è meglio così allora
il coyote china che in italiano e
cotechino non ho capito bene perché
perché non sembra neanche una tipa
sembra un maschio ma è un maschio e la
prima volta mi fanno ammazzare un uomo
perché dovrei esser gioso di nuovo
sempre è gay e per questa catechina
porca eva non potevo sceglierne uno
diverso mica sono tutti uguali questi
potrà essere una quei capelli lunghi
viola maledizione no perché ha le tette
grosse meglio così ma addio mio se siete
dei robot non potete fare una cosa
normale mica è una persona che si
distingue dalle altre casinò vedono
quanto larga ma veramente io potevo
vedere attraverso il muro il bersaglio e
non lo sapevo scusa un attimo ma
veramente quindi se io vado quali solo
trovo fai parte del club rituale
broadcast ranzani che vai a sinistra
sinistra si sta perfetto limite entra in
questa scala non li [__] eva se non
ci fosse quella dietro se non ci fosse
questa dietro madonna la madama tutte e
due
niente sempre in mezzo alla gente du
palle poter scegliere un tipo sociale
per uccidere nic in classe junior ho mai
tempo non ci arriverò mai tempo non ci
arriva dai veloce premia il braccio ok
abbiamo del tempo prima che finisca la
lezione per sbarazzarci della tizia no
voi non avete visto niente ride è visto
niente sono nuda nipote aiuto polizia
over cioè
ero a [__] a è difficilissimo e
difficilissimo storia qui di merda il
macello o ragazzi una volta nella vita
ce la farò a fare una cazzo di missione
cioè non ci voglio credere
generates o una coi capelli che si
distingue mosso tutti quei capelli rosa
tutte ragazzi dove minchia è finita ma
l'opera ma sono le 7 20 dove è andata
questa vuole marinare la scuola lo so io
non so come si dice lavoro per unire il
giorno di con universo marinare bigiare
tagliare tutti i diversi io dicevo
tagliare a scuola mia va beh quando
salti la scuola ecco è quella che quella
lì mica e quell'amica sul tetto si sta
limo nando che scena sto vedendo cosa
stai facendo non si origlia schifosa tra
tutte le cose che poteva fare prescuola
dovendo niente va a spettegolare per
un'ora la mattina
renditi conto di quanto se inutile se io
adesso mi metto a parlare con la zia qua
parla parla parla parla ci non lei porca
eva una cosa devi fare una cosa sola
devi fare quanti problemi può essere
quella verde licra fermani salve non ha
questa è una mazza di sta allenando
perché c'è la partita di quidditch ma
porca [__] che botta in faccia so
provare a uscire problema che non so
quanta gente ci sia fuori
ok via libera vi arrivare mi conosce
nessuno esco dalla porta principale nome
non ci credo sono uscito dalla porta
principale anti sgamo full adesso
siccome anche quegli stronzi davanti a
cessino dovranno mangiare ci saranno
tolti di mezzo prego iddio che stessa
roba non lo so l'inceneritore veloce
perfetto bene adesso ci siamo
ciao ciao piccolo gattino questa no no
che su smacchia non sto macchiando tutto
di sangue mi butterei io lo stesso posso
buttarmi all'inceneritore anch'io è
stato il gatto si vedono chiaramente le
sue orme è stato il gatto ragazzi che le
prove sono schiaccianti
allora
non ho parole
vi giuro non a parole sono esterrefatto
c'è quindi al 115 spa un anno così
davanti al bel bidone dal nulla come le
tartarughe ninja
devo lavarmi andare a pulire al piano di
sopra
prima mi lavo poi mi rivesto addio che
fatica la vita da killer non esistono
più gli omicidi di una volta come si fa
quasi ti ringrazio gesù bene stato più
semplice del previsto guarda lo immagino
che l'arma del delitto non si possa
pulire bene quindi devo prenderla ok non
c'è nessuno grazie a dio la tipa andata
perfetto ragazzi non mi rimane che
pulire il casino che ho fatto e ci sono
un paio di impronta a terra soprattutto
vicino al gattino
non vorrei mai lincoln passero lui
perché non vorrei mai avere un gattino
morto io sono una brava persona felice
una bruciante quarto perfetto scusami
gatto beh bravo piccolo bene ragazzi
sono le quattro afterschool e io direi
che il mio lavoro qui con questa
impronta qua è ufficialmente finito
stavolta è stato perfetto e mi hanno
sbagliato niente posso anche svuotare
fantastico no anche riempito d'acqua è
risultato così seppure sciacquato
ragazzi abbiamo finito la tipa è morta
tutto incenerito pure la mazza da
baseball tutte le orme pulite c'è più un
cazzo e io direi che posso tornare a
casa grazie mille di avermi accompagnato
in questo viaggio della madonna sia
fammi vedere che ho vinto dammi il
risultato finale dove c'è scritto fa vj
sei un fenomeno grazie ne ho bisogno
[Musica]